here I'll tell you something um I was
wrong about because as you guys know I'm
right about almost everything uh but you
know what I was really wrong about I
remember when they first
um uh put the special prosecutor on
Donald Trump when Robert Mueller was
first assigned to him I was just
convinced I knew obviously there was
going to be nothing with a Russian
conspiracy because I knew that was all
made up
um and Libertarians know not to trust
the CIA but I really did think they
would get him for something I was just
like the guy was a real estate developer
in New York City he's got to have some
dirt on him you can't rent an apartment
in New York City without committing at
least a misdemeanor uh I figured they'd
find something and it is amazing that
after all of this time they're still
they still just have to make up a
non-prime and then charging with 32
counts of the same non-crime